russia is pushing finland and sweden
toward nato
um
this is a bloomberg story last month the
russian foreign minister committed
comments about finland and sweden
indicating displeasure with the idea of
either joining the alliance but this
approach may well
have backfired on the russians and
increased the desire of both nordic
nations to seriously consider membership
it represents an opportunity for nato
given the character geography and
military capability of the two countries
technologically both nations
operate high-end combat equipment
notably the swedish air force which
flies
locally produced saab gripen strike
fighters they these were used to uh
excellent military effect in the combat
operations in libya in 2011 under my
command filling just ordered 64 lockheed
martin f-35 fighters the most advanced
combat aircraft in the world and then
i'll read the story prior to that before
that which goes with it about blinking
this is a real clear politics story if
russia attacks ukraine
nato will reinforce the baltic states
and poland secretary of state anthony
bilkin blinken said that negotiation
with russia over ukraine continue and
warned if russia commits renewed
aggression against ukraine i think it's
a very fair prospect that nato will
reinforce its uh positions along the
eastern flank the countries that border
russia poland and the baltic republics
of lithuania
lithuania latvia and estonia are the
only members of nato directly bordering
russia how we got here is because russia
has committed repeated acts of
aggression against its neighbors going
back more than a decade georgia
moldova and ukraine in 2014 and now the
prospect of doing that again lincoln
said do you think russia or putin
listens to blinking and says oh my gosh
that just scared me do you think that's
what putin says when he hears blink and
speak i don't think so no i mean i think
i think uh words are useless and your
actions are the only thing that matters
and they look at afghanistan and they go
really
we we've heard you talk before blinking
and so i mean i i don't think so again
you just look at what look at what they
do during one administration versus the
next yeah right i mean i think you you
focus on what people do what they as
opposed to what they say uh lots lots of
lots of talk i'm never concerned about
what i see russia doing i'm always
concerned about what i don't see them
doing um why they're creating a
distraction in one place and what are
they doing somewhere else uh great i
mean they produced some of the greatest
chess players in the world yeah thinking
thinking through the strategy the long
term proxy proxy proxy nonstop that was
all his game that was my third question
because that's what he did with armenia
and azerbaijan it said non-stop procs
what just happened with uh kazakhstan
yeah i mean
very interesting the under-reported
color revolution in kazakhstan like they
overthrew their entire their entire
government overnight they they
arrested them but there's something that
that was reported that was denied
immediately before anybody knew it was
reported which made it very very suspect
about the uh the the bio weapons load
that apparently russia had stolen bio
weapons from an american facility in
kazakhstan and it was denied before it
was reported which was very very very
strange it came out in the daily mail it
was never even reported in america
so you know like you talk talk about
these proxy wars and you know these
coordinated you know efforts by these
autocrats and you say man we're running
out of proxies
we're we're running out of these border
countries to have these color
revolutions and like eventually
the borders are going to meet each other
and you're not going to be able to push
anymore i mean look america is going to
color revolution right now we can
disagree about it call it a conspiracy
all you want look at the definition of a
colored revolution you think anything
that happened over the last three years
came from inside our borders or do you
think there were people inside our
borders that were working with
international factions
we talk about this all the time how high
you're up how high up i mean as high as
it goes you have global interest versus
local interest now pat i think we're you
know we've talked about this at length
we don't have a lot of time to go into
it unfortunately but you have
you have people in our country who are
not elected officials and i think that
this is what's happened to our our
government why
we're so vulnerable right now like you
were saying is because look whatever the
administration was we always had the
senate we always had congress
right we always they they always had
their constituents in mind they for lack
of a better term they were the voice of
the people and then you know whoever our
leader was right left whatever it was it
was a small variance but not a lot of
difference it really when you think
about it not a ton of difference between
reagan bush one clinton not a ton of
difference a little bit here a little
bit there little spending this way a
little spending that way but but mostly
the same type of person politically
anyway right 40 yard lines 40 yard lines
perfect example right now we have these
massive swings entire party-wide
you have a senate that's un that can't
function unless it has a clear majority
right so now
everything is a is a national and a
global issue there is no local issues
anymore and our leaders who are elected
by us
are not beholden to us they're beholden
to globalist
interests there's nothing that nobody
can convince me differently and it's not
just nancy pelosi mitch mcconnell the
same way they're more interested in what
china and the eu and the u.n have to say
than they are their district in san
francisco or virginia and you can't
convince me otherwise and that's a major
problem that's a huge issue
how high rupto how high up you think you
think uh uh even presidents
uh uh are playing on other uh you know
different interests where they're
worried about a big guy getting deals in
the ukraine yeah
i mean yeah i mean look
again this guy is about 15 points for
the big guy 15 years of the big guy but
but this this right here man this first
one thing about putin so putin this is
not a guy that when he threatens he's
just threatening you go to a bar guy
says if you do that again i'm gonna
punch you in the face nine out of ten
times it's what the guy's just talking
just talking one out of ten time is
putin
he's not gonna he's not even gonna tell
you he's just gonna punch you in the
face he's not the guy that punches
anything
but the point is that somehow your drink
gets poisoned basically that's what
you're looking at navalny on a flight
radiated salad you know he's going to
give you the polonium hairspray as he
walks past you what is this guy in the
house so so look let's end on a message
i hope though pat man like all right so
what by the way we just got we just got
bored we got a few more minutes because
i got to go to the airport at 11 30. so
we got time
yeah so
who is the you working for america like
you're you're doing god's work working
for
you know the most vulnerable amongst us
tom made a great point before you know
in in my limited government world view
government i'm not an anarchist
government has a place it's to protect
the most vulnerable amongst us and if
our government with
nine trillion dollars at its disposal
over the last three years
can't protect or is unwilling to protect
the most vulnerable why should it exist
if it if it doesn't function at the at
its baseline of upholding the
constitution in the united states and
protecting the most vulnerable among us
why should it exist and why should we be
giving them any more money god aoc i
know you're sick i hope this doesn't
upset you while you're sick and watching
but why should we give these people even
a dollar more if they can't even do that
now
and what if they're not doing that if
they're not looking out for american
citizens and if they're not looking out
for the most vulnerable among us if it
falls on
on private sector to do it
then what are they doing with the money
oh i can tell you what they're doing
with the money but i probably get myself
in a lot of trouble
spending a lot of it on defense they're
spending a lot of it on social security
spending a lot on medicare a lot on
medicaid there's a lot of means down
here i know where he's going we spend
less than four percent of the gdp on on
defense
well we actually need to we actually
need to increase that number two what
percentage is social security medicare
medicaid that's where we got that that's
where 90 percent of his liabilities but
i think he's also going to get
entitlements correct it's the
entitlements and the waste here's a
great example um
we yeah afghanistan's a black eye on our
country i think pretty much everybody
agrees with that regardless of where you
are where you are politically
you're saying the the the sloppy
the sloppy the sloppy execution starting
at reagan i mean you look at the whole
history of it goes all the way back to
reagan charlie wilson's back to charlie
wilson's war i mean it it everyone's got
culpability in it um we freed the people
but we effed up the in-game who lost
their job over that where's
accountability right you were working
for pat pat would fat would have sent
you packing he would help you go you
know excel elsewhere but it's not going
to be in one of his companies if you if
you screw up that bad as my guess right
because there's accountability where is
the accountability right you look at the
way that's the arc thing you say
accountability this is the response
system is failing because it's supposed
to be us
and there's my point um so the the
russians have the internet research uh
the ira the internet research agency
right which is basically a huge troll
farm so they you know how are they going
to hit us uh i think was your question a
while ago they're going to use our
liberties against us they're just going
to feed the right people get them into
the right echo chamber and then
radicalize that it's called college
because that's what they do yeah right
the russians the russians and the
communists talk about taking over
academic academia i mean there's plenty
of youtube videos about this from
communist party uh um communist party
meetings and so when we look at this i
would actually say we as the people are
the us
so the i
you want a deliver fund doing
counter-human trafficking work you don't
want the government doing counter-human
trafficking work for this very reason
right you want them arresting people
because no private citizen should have
the ability to restrict the liberty of
another private citizen that's what you
need the government for but where does
that actual work
on violence we talk about the we talk
about the um the uh
military-industrial complex guess what
if you there's a reason russia doesn't
have f-35s because they don't have a a
dyncorp northrop grumman
that has a capitalist incentive in order
to make a better and better weapon so we
need those things um
but at the same time we as a people need
to need to keep that in check and say
all right let's regulate tech so that we
can keep these foreign actors out nobody
nobody wants that more than than the
tech companies let's incentivize them to
make sure that they have safe harbor and
they have a reason a business case
to
to regulate themselves right to
self-regulate the same way that banks do
with anti-money laundering laws right um
you you look at the way that we the
banking system i think is actually the
best one right with the banking system
and the way that anti-money laundering
laws work is a really really good model
for um for countering uh
for for countering
foreign on that though because tech
isn't
again the tech even though they may be
american companies they're very clearly
alphabet in particular very very clearly
behold into foreign interests but that's
why we need to regulate them because
dying
who's regulating them so one you said
the government shouldn't regulate them
which i agree but then when they
self-regulate look at what they're doing
now the government they've got
demonetized they've demonetized people
who have been proven to tell the truth
me among them they've taken down pages
they've taken down posts patches had an
interview that was taken down i know for
what for what reason
so that's that's they're regulating
right now they're self-regulating right
now but that's not they're sensory i say
the government government needs to
regulate them
we and and by the government i mean we
the people need to regulate them by
telling our politicians what regulations
they want i mean i hate to make a
slippery slope argument but i mean i
just read
tyler shift you can pull it up there's a
guy who's been number two of the fbi
for
16 years and he said that you know
conservatives should be put in
re-education camps that there needs to
be surveillance on anybody who's donated
to a right-wing candidate in america
this is the number two sure at the fbi
and that's who's gonna regulate and at
the same time do you know where the two
percenter community came from on the far
right
came from military predominantly within
the special operations community so so
we got to keep in mind that that within
the government there is a there
it's the government
the people who work in the government
are of the people right so with it
within the military but i mean you would
know better but yes no i i 99 of the
people working in the cia are are ivy
leaguers now that's nice is that is that
of the people no that's not actually not
true that is not true at all
most of the people that that was the
case in the 50s
most of the people at the cia want you
to believe they're an ivy leaguer and i
say this as an ivy leaguer who worked at
the cia um we i'm like i was a very
conservative guy i mean i'm i'm a you
know
i'm a christian conservative guy
um pretty pretty easy to figure out
where i where i stand politically
and and yet i was uh country chief uh
for a
a kinetic unit um
within the cia within within a
classified unit so uh point is like how
did i raise to such a such a high level
so quick
um the political ideology and a lot of
conspiracy theories that you that you
hear about that internally like just
doesn't get taken into into account um i
know folks at the fbi who are are
um who are about as far right as you can
get i also know folks who are about as
far left yeah i don't i don't want you
guys to be right or left nick i'm just
saying what was the last president we
have didn't go to an ivy league school
was the last vice president we have
didn't go to an ivy league school it was
the last secretary of state we had today
but that's that's a whole other
conversation because the at the end of
the day it's just not over the people
though but the people who make the
government run
are of the people i mean they very much
are the the soldiers on the ground in
afghanistan yeah are not conservative
you would actually find the major
majority of your soldiers on the ground
especially within the conventional rakes
or actually you would probably consider
them pretty liberal i would imagine so
because they come most of them are going
to come from economically uh
economically challenged areas that's
that's not true is it not true no that
is not true that is total myth um in
fact when you look at when you look at
the the military writ large and i don't
know if this was your experience it's
it's uh it's predominantly middle class
it's predominantly middle class you
describe his middle class how wide of a
of a birth are you giving that uh i mean
i would say you know dad is usually blue
collared making somewhere i mean in my
day so that was the 90s you know 50 to
100 a year
because if you're making 100k in iowa
you're crushing it you're making 100 k
in jersey you're barely good right but
about 80 80 of the military is i'm sorry
most of the military actually comes from
rural america and rural america is about
80 percent of the population of or at
least the land the land area you're
saying it's not the bottom percent is
that's not about twenty percent middle
class got it not all um a lot of a lot
of college educated a lot of college
educated um people who and and the
reason this is an important part of the
conversation is there's this myth
uh that people join the military because
they have no other option
i had tons of options an appointment to
the air force academy and i chose to be
an enlisted guy because that's the job i
wanted to do i wanted to give back and i
wanted to serve right pat had plenty of
options right but you know
no
i had a 1.8 gpa in high school so i'm
more from the story that easter i was
low-income
uh welfare baby that i joined the
military but when i was in
uh and i'm thinking about it it was a
lot of middle-income families that
joined
it was middle and low i can't give you a
lot of uh
uh
folks who were from you know great
families and if they were not great
families money-making families and if
they were they went straight into
uh being officers it wasn't enlisted for
you to become an elicit you made a
choice guys guys like you would have
never been enlisted a lot of guys like
you when i remembered that they went
straight to becoming you know second
lieutenant's day one first lieutenant's
captain that's the route they they took
at least when i was at that unit i think
a lot of the and i ran into this at the
cia too there were a lot of folks from
very wealthy families who were very
quiet about the fact that they were from
very wealthy families right and they i
think there's a minority group there i
don't disagree that that's that is a
minority i don't know if that's a
majority so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you